So here's the actual definition of Coco
values that we're going to use and
they come from the [INAUDIBLE] work.
So the coco value of a game is
going to be defined like this.
Let's imagine that we've got a general
sum game with a notation I'm going to
use is U is the payoff to you and
U bar is the payoff to not you, right?
The other person.
>> Yeah, that makes sense.
Although I like that you use the bar
because that means complement.
>> Yeah.
>> So you're saying we
complement each other.
>> This has nothing to do with me.
>> It said you.
>> It has something to
do with you [LAUGH].
>> Okay, now you're just
confusing me with your pronouns.
>> All right, sorry.
So I should have called
the other matrix I.
No wait, that's not going to help.
All right, so the general sum game that
we're actually solving here is U, U bar.
And why don't we just compute say a nash
equilibrium of that general sum game.
Well there's a bunch of reasons,
one is that they're hard to compute.
Another is that maybe it would
be indifferent to getting
those extra bananas and
sharing them around.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to define the coco value and
we're going to use the coco value
to actually divide the spoils.
Here's how the coco values defined,
we're going to take
the general sum game U, U bar.
And we're going to turn it into sort
of redistribute all those utilities
that are in those two matrices.
To create two matrices,
one that's purely cooperative and
one that's purely competitive.
We're going to create one game by
thinking about the average values that
the two of us would get for each of
the different possible joint actions.
>> Sure.
>> So imagine that we would
just get whatever we get and
then we split it evenly.
>> Okay.
>> All right,
that's very cooperative, right.
>> It's very cooperative.
>> And in fact mathematically,
it's just U plus U bar over 2,
it becomes the matrix payoff that
we're both going to abide by.
>> It's injuries more.
>> Purely competitive version is for
us to look at the difference between
the utilities that we get and
split that in half, right?
So it ought to be the case that if
we add these two matrices together,
U plus U bar over 2 and
U minus U bar over 2.
What we get U for my perspective,
sorry, from U's perspective.
And we get U bar from
the perspective of the other player.
So we recover those same utilities
from the general sum game.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But again, we've redistributed
into these two matrices,
one of which is purely cooperative,
we get the same payoffs.
And the other one is pretty
competitive because one of us
is playing U minus U bar over 2.
And I was playing the negation of
that which is U bar minus U over 2.
Right, so what's good for you is bad for
the other player and vice-versa.
>> Okay.
>> In particular,
this is zero sum game now.
>> I was actually going to ask what
would happen if you were playing a zero
sum game?
Then U plus U bar would
always be zero and in fact,
this would say you do
minimax on the gap.
>> U plus U bar would always be zero.
Yeah, once we've redistributed
these into a new U and U bar, yes.
And so right and so
what's the Nash like thing with
the equilibrium like thing to do
when we're playing a purely competitive
game and that's to take minimax.
So we're actually going to compute
the minimax value of that game and
we're going to compute
match the max max value.
In other words, which cell has
the highest sum payoff or average.
If you say sum and average is the same.
Find the cell that has
the largest thing and say okay,
well that is also a Nash equilibrium
of the purely cooperative game.
because if we choose the square that has
the highest payoff out of everything,
then we're going to have no incentive
to switch to something else.
>> That's right.
>> How do we compute
the cooperative equilibrium?
>> You just replace all the things with
their sum and take the biggest one.
>> So it's like taking a max
of all the cells on matrix.
>> A max of all the of the new sales.
>> Of the new meter, that's right.
And what about minimax?
Do you know I remember how to do that?
>> No, I do, I've tried to
remember which one is which,
well, let's pretend I don't
remember how to do it.
>> Anything that's not a dynamic
program is a linear program.
>> And truer words never been spoken.
>> [LAUGH] Because it's
all about programming.
>> [LAUGH]
>> All right, so in particular, you
can set this this problem up as a linear
program and solve it in polynomial time.
So this is efficient.
At least you know in a formal
mathematical computer science-y
kind of sense.
And so is this.
>> Right.
>> So we took up a game that we
actually don't know how to solve because
computing a Nash equilibrium can be
really hard and
we've broken up into two.
Again, just by redistributing the
wealth, redistributing the utilities.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We actually split it up into two
games that are the same amount of
utility is being spread around.
But we can actually compute
the equilibrium value for
both of them really easily.
And then we're just
going to add them together.
>> Okay, and
then what does it tell us to do?
>> Good question.